[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing 25 words from the harry
potter series that seemingly everyone
even myself on some occasions pronounces
wrong in r the fan's defense however the
world of harry potter is flash with all
sorts of peculiar naming conventions
whether it's referring to a potion which
changes one's physical appearance
polyjuice potion or a magical creature
that's spread out of cross-brooding
manticores and fire crabs blast and
screwed this list of course extends to
all manners of people places and things
the inspiration for this video came from
pronunciation related comments stemming
from the comment section of this channel
over the last two years where i've
noticed that some people are awfully
quick to voice what they feel is the
correct pronunciation despite the
obvious absence of any sort of attempt
to research said pronunciation i know i
know you read it in the book like that
when you were a kid but guess what that
doesn't make it right furthermore some
of the intended pronunciations are
completely bizarre and no right-minded
person would pronounce them that way
which is why i'm almost certain that
none of you have always pronounced all
of these words correctly i also want to
add that for each word there will be
three variants the correct pronunciation
the most commonly used mispronunciation
into my preferred pronunciation that's
right some words despite being wrong
just won't ever sound okay to me in
their intended manner you're probably
thinking that's sacrilege but once you
hear the list you may feel the same way
let's get into it number one okay this
one is one of the worst for a number of
reasons which is why i'm just going to
get it out of the way
no one pronounces this one correctly and
that's because it's true pronunciation
is bizarre are you ready
canuts yes it's a hard k most commonly
i've heard it mispronounced as nudes
which makes sense but unfortunately not
everything makes sense in the wizarding
world
i'm probably criticized for this word
more than any other on the channel
cannots are of course the lowest form of
wizarding currency behind galleons and
sickles in value number two another
massively contentious word this one
refers to a witch or wizard who is able
to transform their physical form at will
the two pronunciations vying for the
throne in this particular circumstance
are animagus and animagus most people
lean towards the former however we're
going to hear the hard g being used in
the films furthermore the word animal
used in conjunction with the greek word
magus create the portmento which
comprises the word and magus also uses a
hard g
therefore in this instance i lean
towards the g over the j
this is also one of the rare
circumstances where neither one sounds
particularly bad
three this woman was voldemort's mother
the most common mispronunciation for
this lady's name is marope where in
reality it should be pronounced merapy
four one of harry's irish classmates to
those of you who may have never heard
this congruence of irish syllables
spoken aloud it's only natural that you
pronounced it the way it's phonetically
written
seems however that pronunciation is a
veritable abomination in relation to the
true pronunciation
which is sheamus
5. this character needs no introduction
and goes by many names the dark lord he
who must not be named etc however you
may be surprised to hear that his name
is probably mispronounced more than any
other word in harry potter despite
canuts of course voldemort which is spit
out of the mouths of book readers and
movie fans alike a million times a day
is actually supposed to be pronounced
voldemort as it's technically comprised
of three french words vol d and more
which put together mean flight of death
however this word is a perfect and rare
example of a word that i will never
pronounce properly he will always be
voldemort to me
6. the home of the dursleys this english
town is located in the south east in the
county of surrey i've heard some people
pronounce this town as little winging
like the wing of a bird however you may
be surprised to hear it's actually
pronounced little whinging like someone
that won't stop complaining 7. otherwise
known as liquid luck this powerful
little potion helps harry in the
half-blood prince the mispronunciations
associated with this potion aren't too
bad and usually comes down to the
incorrect felix felicis against the
correct felix velicis number eight this
brutal witch was voldemort's right hand
woman the feared death eater in the
wizarding world her maiden name black is
easy enough to say but as it turns out
we've been saying her married name all
wrong
while most of us say bellatrix lestrange
it turns out that it's actually
pronounced lestrange even though i've
studied a fair bit of french i find this
one very unusual to say and i'll
probably keep going with lestrange
9. these are the reanimated corpses of
deceased witches and wizards present in
the cave i was sure i was saying this
one correctly
but i stand corrected
where i would previously say in fairy it
turns out the correct pronunciation is
in theory number ten i'd be lying if i
told you i have ever felt confident
about pronouncing this former aura and
minister for magic's name even with some
internet research i'm still not sure if
it's rufus scrim jaw or rufus scrim gore
i'm leaning towards the former but
perhaps one of you in the comments can
help 11. this centaur lived in the
forbidden forest and even taught
divination at hogwarts
furthermore an e at the end of a word we
don't know always throws a spanner into
the mix it turns out that the commonly
pronounced ferenzi is actually
pronounced firenze
12. this spell which serves a simple
purpose bring an object to the caster is
under all kinds of scrutiny online but
while there are several renditions
floating around from accio to asio it
turns out that akio is the true victor
13. you may have heard of this character
close friend of harry's ron's lover the
brightest witch of her year it turns out
that her name has been brutalized on
many occasions i'll let pottermore
handle this one hermione hermi won
hermione ninny even some of hermione's
most devout fans didn't have the
slightest clue how to say her name
needless to say when the first film hit
cinemas in 2001 there were more than a
few people waiting with baited breath to
hear her to the point introduction
hermione
at last it all made sense
14. this is known as the potion of love
and causes a powerful infatuation from
the drinker
the common debate for this one is
amortentia versus the correct amortentia
which is confirmed on pottermore i
always went by the former
15. this stone-like object comes from
the stomach of a goat and will save you
from most poisons it turns out fans have
over complicated this one pronouncing it
bezoar instead of the correct and much
simpler bezoar 16. this spell used by
voldemort's death eaters fills the sky
with a large projection of the ominous
dark mark i can barely imagine the
countless possibilities for how this
pronunciation could be butchered but let
me bring some clarity to the situation
it's mores madra this is confirmed on
pottermore 17. this is one i say with
utmost confidence despite not knowing
for the life of me whether i'm correct
and as it turns out after doing just a
very minute amount of digging i was
completely off where i previously said
whizzing gamut it turns out the correct
pronunciation is wiesengarmot which just
doesn't quite sit right with me
18.
this french wizarding school visits
hogwarts for the triwizard tournament
competing against hogwarts and
durmstrang as it is a french school it
only makes sense that it has a french
pronunciation
beau baton not box batons
19. this pure blood wizard was a friend
of dumbledore's as well as a member of
the order of the phoenix i think the big
question here is do you pronounce his
last name like the doge meme as it turns
out his name should be pronounced alfies
and not alphaus dogueg 20. this is where
harry lived with the dursie's and where
his hogwarts acceptance letter was sent
much to the confusion of some
this should be pronounced as privet not
private
21. the phoenix is undoubtedly one of
the most spectacular creatures in the
wizarding world and in the harry potter
series we become particularly familiar
with one as it turns out the name of
dumbledore's phoenix companion should be
pronounced as fawkes not four keys 22.
this questionable wizard can be
identified by his less than impressive
reputation as serving the shortest ever
term as minister for magic i've also
never known how to say his first or last
name as it turns out it's meant to be
pious thickness but that still feels
wrong somehow
23. this spell is one of the
unforgivable curses and is used to
torture people
notorious death eater bellatrix
lestrange is a known proponent of the
spell this spell should be pronounced
cruciatus and not cruciatus although i'm
sure there are some that will vehemently
vie for the former 24. this famous witch
and magical historian was the great aunt
of dark wizard gelet grindelwald this
may surprise some but her name should be
pronounced as batilda and not bethilda
this one is of course a joke but do try
to remember that it's leviosa not
leviosa
and that's it for this video which ones
were news to you
comment down below if you enjoyed the
content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel
until next time remember
imperfect understanding is often more
dangerous than ignorance
[Music]
you